abang volleys of tear gas protesters
occupied Baghdad central to her square
while others pushed forward attempting
to reach the highly secured green zone
that's home to government offices and
embassies fed up with high unemployment
and what they call top-level corruption
they're calling for the government to
resign Iraq's military impose an
overnight curfew but many were defiant
no to the curfew we will remain here the
curfew is one of their filthy games and
tales I'm an Iraqi mother my sons have
university degrees I was hoping they
would help me when they graduate but
they're jobless it's dangerous medical
sources say gas canisters fired by
security forces killed three people on
Monday when they took a direct hit to
the head over the past month scores of
people have been killed and thousands
injured this is a popular demand asking
for greater changes greater reforms in
the government and greater services and
this the curfew is obviously a method by
the government to carry out its its
plans by evacuating the the main areas
the main squares of the cities from the
demonstrates demonstrators nationwide
protests began at the start of the month
but pause for two weeks as they waited
for acts leaders to respond to their
demands they returned on Friday with
renewed anger
with a laser sorry not today youth are
not asking for jobs nor for services the
young women want radical and real change
from the regime thousands of University
and school students defied orders and
skipped class to join the protests on
Monday it's a huge challenge for Prime
Minister Ali Optima Hadi who's only been
in power for a year he's promised to
reshuffle the cabinet and introduce
reforms but he's refused the protesters
demand to resign along with this
government the prominent Shia cleric
moqtada al-sadr who controls the largest
bloc in parliament has called on the
government to announce early
parliamentary elections and with nearly
60 percent of iraq's 40 million people
living on less than $6 a day many say
they have nothing to lose and will
continue to fight for a better future
Laura burden manley al jazeera